can Google's new pixel tablet compete
with the iPad well today we're going to
compare everything from the design the
displays the speakers cameras
performance and more people are calling
this the iPad killer and it does seem
like it might be because even though
it's 50 bucks more expensive at the base
it comes with 128 gigs of storage
compared with apple we have to pay
another 150 bucks to go right away up to
256. now First Impressions this thing
feels kind of lightweight and wow that
is very cold here it might look like
plastic but it's not it is metal and you
guys see the pins for the SMART
connector dang this thing feels nice it
reminds me of the older iPad design with
the curved back compared to our iPad
which finally switched to the new flat
side design now as far as weight I think
the pixel one feels a little heavier
here's the exact weight the pixel is a
little bit taller in this orientation
but it is narrower than the iPad and I
really like that the camera is flush on
the bottom compared to the iPad's fairly
big bump that makes it rock on your desk
and what's really cool is that it comes
with this bad boy this is a speaker dock
that you plug into wall kind of like a
Google home but then you have the screen
that goes along with it and when you
snap it on right here bam magnetically
attaches and then you have a smart
speaker with louder audio and I'm
excited to hear how it sounds now both
tablets have USB type-c inputs but the
pixel tablet charges from the base as
well which is the charger they include
and it's a faster charger than Apple's
honestly I wish Apple offered something
like this for the iPads Now setting this
up you guys could see that the iPad has
a larger screen even though it's
marketed as a 10.9 inch whereas Google
they Market this as an 11 inch tablet
both of these do have fingerprint
scanners built into the power buttons
now comparing the displays uh the
sharpness and details practically
identical with both of them they're both
60 hertz displays and then if we open up
just a standard web page and I max out
the brightness both of these are
actually 500 nits of brightness so they
are very similar comparing HDR video I
am surprised by the pixel the contrast
looks great detail looks really good
sometimes it's a little over saturated
the colors definitely look different but
it does look fantastic and it is hard to
tell which one is better but the one
thing I noticed especially in Darker
areas and darker videos is that the
pixel does have deeper blacks and it has
less Reflections as well well because it
has a laminated display compared to a
non-laminated so on the iPad we actually
have a gap between the glass and the
screen and so it does look worse the
pixel has a better screen now both these
tablets look like they have quad
speakers but the iPad actually has some
fake grills it has a dual speaker setup
compared to quad and of course the pixel
comes with that stand so let's go ahead
and do a speaker comparison
familiar bring me back
[Applause]
[Music]
wow guys what a difference the pixel
destroyed the iPad in pretty much every
way louder sound quality better better
bass having those extra two speakers in
those ports actually helps but the crazy
thing is that it also comes with this
docking station so now let's go ahead
and see what difference that makes
[Music]
bring me back
all right guys that was insane you guys
see I have the iPad on this little stand
here
this sounds so dang good it almost
sounds like it's better than Apple's 100
homepod mini so I went ahead and I
grabbed it let's listen the pixel here
[Music]
sounds good and homebot Mini
okay I was wrong
[Music]
let's hear this one
Nadine why did I have to do that well I
didn't have to get the home phone really
up I thought that this sounded better
because it sounds genuinely really good
a lot better than I thought it would
sound so I guess you can get yourself an
iPad and you can AirPlay to your homepod
mini another hundred bucks but the
convenience of having the setup you're
just gonna watch movies on it plug it in
Auto connects quicker I still think it
is killer and apple needs to do this now
getting into the cameras I'm starting
out with the front facing camera and
this is the pixels in video recording
you guys let me know how the microphones
sound and you guys can see it's pretty
cropped in and there's only an option to
actually crop even further but we can't
get very wide and this is the iPad's
camera it also has a centered camera on
the front which is great and with that
it is a center stage camera so you can
actually get very wide like this this so
you have a big field of view and then
some different apps will actually crop
in and track you or you could just crop
in like this let me know how the
microphone sounds and how the camera
quality looks compared to the new pixel
tablet now with that said the pixel does
not offer a keyboard case for it so yes
it's expensive on this one but it is a
nice keyboard and trackpad and you also
cannot use an apple pencil like you can
with the iPad so this product is
definitely more limited in that way and
now let's go ahead and take a picture
here
and then on the iPad
we have 12 megapixels on the iPad
compared to eight and here I think that
the pixels photo actually looks better
because it doesn't have that heavy crop
comparing the rear cameras the pixels is
actually quite a bit wider here but in
terms of quality the iPads does look a
little better but it's not as big of a
difference as I expected getting into
performance our iPad has 4 gigs of RAM
compared to eight and trying to run a
geekbench on here Google literally won't
let us do it now here we have the A14
chip compared to the tensor G2 just like
the pixel has in their 7 Pro and their
7A now thankfully we have the scores
from those phones and as far as single
core the iPad is 50 more powerful and in
multi-core the iPad is 55 more powerful
now in terms of graphics performance uh
we have the numbers from the iPad here
12.2 FPS compared to 9.9 that is a
smaller difference 23 percent more
powerful for the iPad so the A14 is
definitely more powerful than the pixel
tablet and of course the scores could be
slightly different on here if they tuned
it differently unfortunately I wasn't
able to run that but we know the iPad is
killer and with that Apple will give you
at least five years of software updates
in some cases longer so you know as far
as software and the CPU and Longevity
the iPad will be better now that also
leads us to the App Store the Apple App
Store is way better in terms of what's
available and what's optimized compared
to Android tablets so that is definitely
a win for the iPad and to answer the
original question does the pixel tablet
beat out with the iPad or can it compete
well in terms of value out of the box I
mean you get more storage you don't have
to spend 150 bucks more you get that
stand the screen is better the built-in
speakers are quite a bit better so if
you're using it as a media device web
browsing maybe simple apps that are
available I would say yes it's better
but if you want to get a keyboard for it
if you want to get the apple pencil if
you want it to be a computer replacement
and with that I still think that a lot
of people are going to choose the iPad
for the ecosystem but you guys let me
know your thoughts down below we have
links if you want to get the best deal
and get a discounted iPad click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those videos and we'll see you in the
next one
foreign